hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel and i hope you're enjoying
your holiday break i know i am and i
know a lot of you guys including me have
gotten some battery-powered gifts this
holiday season and this is a video to
help you guys out who have been
wondering about the batteries in these i
was actually doing some research on
lithium-ion batteries which is the
rechargeable type of battery that you
find in just about every mp3 player or
phone or device out there and to sum up
my hours of research i basically have
three main myths that i can dispel right
now myth number one is that you need to
do a very long like overnight initial
charge before you can use a lithium-ion
battery-powered device for the first
time this is false lithium-ion batteries
actually don't require any sort of
initial charge or priming is what they
call it so if your new ipod comes with
40 battery out the box you can just
start using it at 40 battery don't worry
about any sort of overnight charge myth
number two is that you should unplug a
device as soon as it's done charging so
you can avoid overcharging and
diminishing the battery life this is one
of the most common myths and i only
recently figured out that this is
actually also completely false
lithium-ion batteries are actually kind
of smart in a way they have built-in
circuits that cut power once the battery
is fully charged if you actually look at
a battery charging chart they charge
really quickly to the first like 80
percent and then they basically
gradually fill in the last 20
and if you look at it really really
closely it actually bounces off 100 a
couple times so it'll go from 100 to
like 97 to 100 to 97 and that's the
battery rejecting the charge saying all
right we're done charging and then when
it gets down to 97 it's like all right
i'll accept a little more but basically
they never get overcharged the only
thing you have to worry about is
overheating and that pretty much never
happens unless you're using it in a
really hot environment so uh you don't
have to worry about whipping it off the
charger in the middle of the night when
it's done charging myth number three is
that you need to calibrate a lithium-ion
battery which is basically people
draining their battery all the way down
to zero percent then charging it all the
way back up again to 100
while this is sometimes true uh and can
sometimes work on certain devices where
it has a battery memory the battery
itself doesn't ever need to be
calibrated it's the phone software
itself that sometimes has trouble
reading the battery percentage left so
you may want to do this every year or so
but lithium-ion batteries have the same
performance level from just about any
percentage discharge the reason these
myths exist is because old battery
technology was nickel based these old
nickel batteries needed to be calibrated
and discharged from 100 to get their
peak performance which is well it's old
technology now so with all that plugging
and unplugging i just saved you i think
uh you owe me a high five or or a thumbs
up i don't know whatever you want to do
either way this has been mkbhd and this
entire video was filmed on a samsung
galaxy nexus hope you guys are enjoying
your holiday season and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace
you